this is a production of Cornell
University
um
so yeah so that's the title of the
presentation
um so I will
um let's just put my time right here
so I will that's the outline of the
presentation
um and again if you have any issues
hearing me by any chance maybe internet
connection just please let me know
Jennifer
um so that the golden bit of terminology
and and a little bit talking about
enteric metan emissions and measurements
um then show some data from metanalysis
that we did here uh last year that
compared grades and confinement then
some dietary strategies to mitigate
methane emissions in in grading systems
and but also some some of some of them
actually more uh at this point apply to
to confinement system but but also
potentially to be used in Dairy in
grazing and some conclusions future
research and questions in terms of
terminology just I know that some of you
may not be familiar but one I'm
referring here to confinement
confinement can be year-round meaning
cows can be on Barn the year round like
for instance most of it varies in U.S
there are a confinement system
um confinement seasonal let's say
pasture-based dairies here in the
Northeast and the Midwest there are
seasoning seasonal meaning you know cows
are confined at this time of the year
because there is no grass to graze and
then during the summer the grazing
season they are out grazing and and
they're they receive different types of
supplements right or food grass diets
uh I'll be talking about total mixer
reaction or TMR uh basically is the
erection where you mix your 40 Source
like hay silage or Haley your grain
Source you know and then minerals and
vitamins you can use a vertical mixer
like you see here in this picture and
and mix all together and offer to the
animal right so a TMR most of the
confinement systems in us very seasoned
feed TMR but you can also have a grazing
Farm where the cows go out and graze and
then when they come back from milking
and after milk they can get a TMR so TMR
is not a synonymous of a confinement you
can feed TMR to a grazing cow
so I'll be talking about dry matter
intake that's equivalent to feed intake
right it's dry matter for instance
because if you want to compare a pasture
sauce which is wet right like 85 dry
matter and hey I mean 85 moisture and
hay that said if that's the opposite so
if you compare this on a fair base so
you use a dry matter system meaning you
dry the samples
um in in 100 degrees Fahrenheit uh or 55
degrees Celsius for 48 hours you remove
most of the water and then you can
compare the nutrient composition on a
dry matter base
and then we're talking about energy
corrected milk basically you're
normalizing here
uh the energy of milk in in on a
assuming 3.5 fat and 3.2 protein in this
way you can compare the Jersey cow right
those brown cows that produce about five
percent butter fat with a hosting cow
that produce about 33.5 fat you can uh
equalize you can normalize uh milk
production on a NH base
a little bit of all the terminology here
when I'm referring to methane production
is basically that absolute amount of
methane that's produced by ruminant
animal and then methane yields and then
you see a lot of methane even intensity
basically grams of methane either per
kilogram of drama intake or DMI or per
kilogram of NH corrected milk
I'm trying to normalize things here to
make those comparisons
uh just to give a shot a very quick
example here where you have a scenario
of a cow a let's say assume that you
produce about 500 grams of almost like a
half pound more than a pound actually of
methane this cause is consumed about 30
kilos of dry matter and she's producing
45 kilos of energy collected milk and
looks like 100 pounds of Spanish no so
you can make these calculations and come
up with uh with the numbers here Matt
they need to be about 17 grams per
kilograms of dramatic intake and methane
intensity about 11.1 let's say this cow
B she produced the same amount of
methane but she's eating less and and
producing less milk so you can see that
the methane yield will be high oops
nothing it would be about 20 percent
higher and methane intensity would be
about 29 higher right so you can have an
idea here how you know when bringing
those numbers to a
normalized base is different
so I guess
sorry to interrupt you you are sort of
going in and out the sound
yep I don't know what's causing that
is better now yeah you sound good now
okay maybe too much
okay I'll try to be close to the
computer so
um I guess the question is why a shark
is doing and Again Jennifer is if you
see this problem again then I can try to
put my uh uh uh another sound system
here
so
um
so what a shark is doing here right so
and this is a tiger shark
um well and and probably not eating a
cow they probably not cross path by any
means but the thing is a cow or ruminant
may be affecting their environment right
so in this there is effects of climate
change on you know shock migration this
is a very recent study that was
published actually this year at the
global change biology where the
researchers are estimating based on
modeling and also tracking these animals
that for every degrees Celsius of of uh
warming temperature in the oceans they
have been tracking this for about 10
years those animals are basically
extending uh their migration further not
right 205 from 150 miles further north
and also they start their whole trip
summer migration uh 14 days earlier
because of the warm temperature so so
you know know that what this would have
impact in the in the in the whole
Ecology of apex predator in the in the
in the in the web chain food chain you
know is a no right so uh that's why
we're focused on math thing
um so and and just compliment what Larry
already mentioned so a cow as a ruminant
and and this is not only a cow ruminance
in general that include sheep goats uh
wildly ruminants like deer moves those
animals they have one stomach with four
compartments and the four compartments
are shown here the rumen the reticulum
the amazing and the album Amazing the
Roman reticulous and amazing it's a an
aerobic environment with billions of
microbes Like Larry mentioned the album
Mason is equivalent to our stomach
basically have has the same functions of
this every stomach of humans I produce
enzymes that mostly digest protein right
so and here's just a view of the of the
full room and you can see it really uh
uh the space that hilarious makes is
very huge fermentation that all the left
side of the animal you can see the
reticulum right here right and just for
a reference the heart is right here and
as I said there are billions of microbes
from protozoa uh General they are Kia
and also fungi and yeast
um a little bit of the room in
fermentation again to complement
complement what Larry said so these
animals are consuming feed and this
coming from a forest Source like silage
or hay or drink Source like corn for
instance
um so you you need to think this
basically can divide it into measure
carbohydrate Source fiber and starch the
microbe the microbes will attack fiber
and then starting to start to degrade
right and start to decompose and release
glucose
first set of microbes coming in and use
glucose as ionic Source right and and
they produce what Larry mentioned as a
microbial protein so microbial protein
will be a major source of protein when
it passed through this morning passed
right so you'll get digestion and
release amino acids for those animals
it's a high quality protein and is
manufactured by the microbes because of
the symbiotic relationship with the
ruminant right so the glucose
and then it's further fermented and
there is byproducts of glucose
fermentation right so
hydrogen like gases CO2 and methane uh
and also the the vfas of Vault of fatty
acids which are acetate and percolonate
and butyrate so those would be absorbed
to the Roman wall right and then goes to
the blood and in the liver will be
utilized I think that's important here
uh acetate is used for fat production in
the mammary gland for making butter fat
butyrates also for fat production and
carbonate is used for glucose production
so in other words the the ruminants
basically use those byproducts of
microbial fermentation to make milk Like
Larry mentioned this extensibly
foreign
so nothing that Larry mentioned that's
also showing here is you have this
positive correlation between dramatic
intake and methane production in other
words as intake goes up
enteric methane production also goes up
right this positive correlation this
equation here a coefficient coefficient
of correlation of 0.86 period high and
and that's why you know it comes down
why why we should be mitigating methane
um the reasons one that obviously is
reduce the carbon footprint of dairies
but also methane represents nhlers Like
Larry mentioned as well so this could be
between three and ten percent like in
this study done by new but it can range
from two to twelve percent depending
where you looked at but the point is
methane also represents energy loss and
that that energy that's not that's not
captured into milk production right
because it's lost uh through burps and
that's very important to identify this
uh so in this is a kind of a joke here
but the point here
uh 95 of the methane is burped right and
and only five percent comes to the other
end we have flatland so
um the point here to say some of the
technology that has been used now to
measure methane
Focus only on the 95 right that's a show
in a minute here
um
so and and to finalize this process
about metallogenesis and theric
maternogenesis so like Larry mentioned
methane is it's it's basically
synthesized by methanogens so they are
Kia the microbes that are in the room
and you can see them here these blue
cells here that are attached to a
protozoa cell they have also symbiotic
relationship
um but methane
is used as a CO2 and hydrogen the
microbes CO2 and hydrogen to make
methane a substrate right
um in the metabolic pathway of acetate
production one of those vfas right
um and and and
you can see that hydrogens are released
when you produce acetate so in other
words diets that are high in cellulose
or in fiber
usually you have more methane because
the pathway leads to more production of
acetate and acetate leads to more
production of hydrogens which is which
is about which is a substrate for the
methanogens to produce methane
on the other hand
in the metabolic pathway that produce
propulating the room and by the microbes
use hydrogen so it's a hydrogen sink
like Larry mentioned so uh like
starch-based diets like corn usually you
have more propionate production or
increased propionate production which
use hydrogen so that means less hydrogen
so the microbes to make methane that's
why a more grain-based diet was
supplemented diet that has more green
usually you reduce methane has less
methane production and that is at a very
high
um and here are some of the ways that
you can actually measure methane
um so
um you can see here that's what
hilarious mentioned like a respiratory
chamber that's that's been being
installed in Cornell so that's
considered the gold standard for methane
measurements because you can see uh it
basically the cow is in the chamber all
the gases and not only the rumen to the
Berks but also to the flatulence the
flattest all this gas are actually
measured right so the downside of this
equipment is the fact that when the cows
are in inside
uh of course that can affect their
intake and if it affects intake it can
you know uh bias methane production but
again I I still consider the gold
standard uh they're now using this uh uh
uh kind of uh either uh
panels here that the cows can see each
other because uh in the past they didn't
used to have those so that's important
so the cows can at least see each other
and another a lot of small issue of this
system here you keep the animals there
for a couple of days only you know two
or three days just because it can affect
the intake and you don't want to that
happen so
um there's some new technologies like
the Green Feed system that is shown here
that we use here to at the University of
New Hampshire uh basically
uh they see some functions like you have
a cow it's basically a head chamber
right so basically in this case you only
capture not only but the captain most of
the matter involved 95 of the methane
that's produced by the animal capturing
and measuring right it's coming from the
Roman and Via burps uh so the cows were
RFID in the ear it's basically a tag
that triggered the system which then
automatically release uh some grains so
why the cows are eating grain and
burping and and
a rook stating basically releasing gas
so there are sensors here that can
actually measure methane and CO2 and
even hydrogen and oxygen so uh there is
a head position sensor that babies the
cow is too far away will not take the
measurement so the measurement is very
reliable right so the good thing about
this system
uh it is you can have animals visiting
like we have here and now there in the
organic Dairy so cows can come and and
visit like five six times a day right so
you have several measurements uh during
the day and you can do during multiple
days right so you can like we usually
take measurements in a study uh from
beginning to the end that may last up to
80 Days 90 days of measurements right so
you have more numbers right more spot
measurements
um here's the setup of the same
equipment for grazing so you can also
have the system set up for a grazing you
can see the solar panels so what you do
here we have the cows on pastures
visiting and when you move cows you know
in our system have a rotational grazing
as the cows move we keep moving the
equipment together
um
so it's it's it's a very uh nice system
just another version of this system that
you that uh uh Paul Conan off at uh
University of Nebraska use quite a lot
is they call the head box system as you
can see here kind of similar
uh uh type of uh technology you'd say
um and in this case it's basically cows
needs to be a nice and they stall but
you can see
um you know you basically capture uh uh
methane that's producing the movement
right
um and then you also have this used to
be very common now it's less with the
Green Feed coming into the picture uh
this is the sf6 or the x or fluoride
tracer technique or this we did here at
UNH as well basically have this tubing
here that goes close to the nostril of
the cow that capture the gas and then we
basically and the gas is accumulated
here in those canisters you remove uh
the tubing here get the syringe get the
gas sample and then you put in the you
analyze in the gas chromatograph from
methane right so when you use the the
Tracer because at the same time
we have our sf6 which is basically a
capsule that the cows will swallow and
release sf6 so we do a ratio between sf6
and methane and it came up with the
calculations so that's uh another way
you can also use this system like this
for cows that are grazing right so
um
so and we I talk a lot about methane and
just going to quickly mention here uh if
you want to see the whole Farm emissions
you need to consider also nitrogen I'm
not spend too much time talking about
nitrogen here
um but when you talk about nitrogen
uh you know like Larry said a lot of
those diets nowadays in the U.S the the
we we have been reducing a lot the
nitrogen concentration the protein of
those diets however
pasture-based diets just by default
usually are higher in nitrogen because
of grass specifically if the grass is is
mature I mean immature uh early in the
seasonal Lush pasture has very high
levels of nitrogen so in those
situations you end up having an
unbalanced supply of energy and nitrogen
in the room and when this happened so
you have more of the nitrogen basically
leaking out in other words you see a
substantial amount of nitrogen being
excreted in the urine in the form of
urea that's very reactive right of some
nitrogen going out in the form of feces
or fecal nitrogen and you have a lower
proportion of nitrogen being converted
into milk protein that's what you
right we want to see as much as possible
dietary nitrogen and dietary protein in
actually converted into milk protein
that's the goal so when you have too
much nitrogen in diet that's more
difficult and a lot of this nitrogen get
lost
right and and convert into nitrates that
can contaminate water and and and soil
um you can also have other other chains
like some of the nitrogen can be
converted into ammonia that is or some
risk for human health and and and also
I'm sorry and also for nitrous oxide
right which is measured in-house gas
right so even though I'm not talking
much about the nitrogen side here is
important to look into that as well
um so I cover a little bit of the
terminology uh enteric methane now I'll
get into
um a little bit of the comparison
comparisons between grazing and
confinement systems
um what we did here before I get into
this the question is why Grace right so
well grazing before you know multiple
ecosystem service right from pollination
erosion control nutrient cycling now the
unique aspects of grazing is the milk
right milk from cows that are on grass
usually have higher concentrations of
omega-3 fatty acids which has been
linked to to better human health right
that's it's it's it's it's
well uh approved and they have more uh
um
omega-3 fatty acids and cows that are
consuming TMR right so also
pasture-based systems are perceived to
be more environmentally friendly more
Animal Welfare friendly by consumers
bastrous is a very cheap it's probably
the cheapest feed store so if you have
more pasture in the diet that's can
probably benefit the bottom line there
in terms of economics
um so overall there are outstanding
opportunities for market capitalization
on pasture-based dairies specifically
you know grass-fed there is right now
right breast fat Dairy grass-fed beef
right so the products are more uh you
pay more the farmers receive more for
those products are there some issues
um uh let's say issues but necessarily
uh things that you need to consider in
front on a dairy on a grazing far one we
know if you look at here this comparison
is steady from Fernando Bargo in from
Penn State they looked at the diet that
was TMR calls or on confinement getting
TMR
they're grazing but supplemented with
TMR thorough mixed ration uh or they're
grazing and getting some grain some
concentrate right and you can see that
the intake that cows that are grazing
are usually lower than intake that the
cows are on confinement receiving TMR
therefore milk production also goes down
right to see the grazing cows that are
grazing and and supplemented TMR has
less milk production in cows that were
grazing and receiving grain uh they're
also producing less milk of course this
can have implications on economics of a
giving Dairy right
um another aspect and this is maybe it's
kind of things obvious is the cows that
are grazing they spend more energy
because they have to walk and they have
to basically uh uh feed themselves right
so that's why in this study here they
compare the confinement and that's the
energy expenditure in kilojoules per
kilo of metabolic body weight and you
can see the housing confinement you
spend less energy than cows that are
grazing that's again obvious reason here
best because Calcutta Grace they need to
move right and and these will get
feedback of course if they spend more
time grazing more energy to graze so
less energy is is available for
producing milk right that's that's some
um and and of course they spent 21 more
energy
basically to Grace so and that energy is
not going to milk production that's why
milk products can usually decline when
Celtic raisin and also uh seeding date
um so why confinement well
usually have more drama intake
I have more milk and milk components
usually have better feed efficiency cows
have better body condition
uh cows are not exposed to inclement
weather sometimes it's it's even in the
summer you know uh there are where there
can be really difficult for the skulls
specifically heat stress in some parts
of the country even here now in the
Northeast so uh confinement you know
you have those Advantage right so we
came up with idea here with my grad
students to kind of build up a
um a data set to to compare uh feed
intake milk production and methane
emissions in dairy cows that were on
confinement or grazing right so it's
kind of difficult because there is not a
lot of studies that has done that
meaning uh making those comparisons and
what we did here we we have this this
flow here to select the the the papers
that has been published in the
literature we identify them we screen
them then we make we choose papers that
are eligible and then include a knot in
the data set so we start with a total
hits of a thousand papers and we end up
with only eight studies and why you have
only eight studies based on the
literature is because again what are you
looking for where it said is that
simultaneously evaluate in the same
study right a treatment or a diet that
cows were in confinement and a diet or
two diets the that the cows were
actually grazing and not many Studies
have have done that so and also we
eliminate papers where for instance if
they don't report the drama intake or
individual drama intake from cows
on pasture we did not uh include those
papers uh so we ended up having the
short numbers of papers that we end up
with a total of 10 because there are two
studies that we did here at UNH that are
not yet published but we included in the
data set so we end up with a total of 10
studies so and and the way they should
be looking at as far as plot here
it basically it's it compares the mean
difference between the the confinement
and and the grades what you should be
looking here on your left side is all
the the studies that we include in the
data set and you see all the comparisons
but the focus here should be in this
diamond here in the bottom that shows
that on average right in terms of intake
or dramara intake cows that are grazing
they they are they they consume about
2.5 kilos less feed or about five pound
less feed and this was you know
statistically significant right so again
going back to what we discussed so cows
that are great and they need to walk to
find their feet right the food when you
look at milk production
the same
uh the same Trend here right you see the
diamond here in the bottom that's the
overall average difference and cows that
are grazing they basically uh producing
about 3.6 kilos less milk about seven
seven and a half pounds less milk right
and the same goes for milk fat
production uh they're producing less
milk fat and they are also producing
glass milk protein right so so of course
this can have implications on as I said
before on the economics and
profitability of those dairies that are
on the grazing uh even though pasture is
this cheap feed Source uh you know the
the the the economics may play a role
here uh when you drop milk components
because farmers are paid based on enough
right so so that's something that needs
to be evaluated
um and and you know as we move along
so we also estimate and and methane
production between confinement and
grazing one thing I want to highlight
here uh folks be a little bit careful
when looking into this data because
only few studies actually report methane
production most of these studies did not
measure methane production so what we
did we estimate methane production using
an equation after a new at all in 2018
so you need to be careful when you look
at this data but there's as I said it's
very limited information out there so
what we did
we use the equation and we estimate
methane production and you see that the
cows that are grazing they produce less
methane uh on a product on on a absolute
amount of absolute base this is It's we
expected because they consume less feed
and then they produce less methane
um we did not see a difference right on
methane U that's grams of methane per
kilogram of drama intake it's the
p-value of 0.83 here but we saw a trend
in in methane intensity which is grams
of methane per kilogram of NH corrected
milk sold cows that were grazing they
tend to uh to be less to to basically to
be to produce more methane per kilo of
NH correct milk and a p-value of zero
zero eight is a statistical Trend it's
not significant but it's a statistical
Trend
um when you look at milk nitrogen
efficiency that means
uh uh the higher the number the better
because that would indicate that more of
the the dietary protein is converted
into milk protein right and that's what
we want to see and uh even though the
grazing was less efficient than the the
confinement this was not a statistically
significant again if you have more
studies
more power maybe those numbers will be
different but with the number of studies
that we use only 14 treatment mean
comparison that's a low number so you
know uh folks need to be careful when
interpreting these results but it's it's
it's a start here on this process
um so I basically discussed a lot about
individual
um uh uh cow production data and and and
now we're trying to move more into whole
Farm emissions trying to do some
comparison here using some uh the the
integrate farm system model from those
three studies that it studies from
Victor Cabrera lab and also for Aaron
silver ball from Wisconsin
uh what they're looking here again is
the the integrated Farm systems model
that Larry also shows some data from
Cornell
um for New York farms and and again this
model takes account uh uh several
aspects of a font right from the
harvesting from the milk production from
fertilization uh carbon sequestration
and so forth so it tries to uh is almost
like a life cycle analysis from from our
rods that develop this model
um and I was showing here
uh some data from Wisconsin very far
those were organic dairy farms based on
a survey with 69 organic dirty Farms So
based on the survey they're able to make
those clusters which basically Farms
that are either they look like or
they're different and they group those
funds four groups and you can see here
some of them have higher milk products
milk production per cow per year like
clusters one and two and some have more
feeds use more feeds than others but
what you can see here the major
difference between those clusters was
was basically cursed to one and two
where plus the one they have more feeds
and feed more grain
um while cluster two so
um they basically have uh uh plus the
two we have more pasture in the diet
right so this kind of white portion here
it's equivalent to pasture they also
have uh a little bit of concentrate uh
more simple diets compared to the
cluster one or have hay corn silage uh
also concentrate uh and and all the feed
stuff so those are the major difference
cluster three and four were intermediate
between those two so
what they did also here was to run the
model and compare uh those theories in
terms of the whole Farm greenhouse gas
emissions in in kilograms of CO2
equivalent per per ton of energy
corrected milk and what they found out
was that the cluster 2 which is the one
that has the highest proportion of
grazing or the the more time of cows and
pastures you can see here that's the
grazing time on pasture in a year base
right ranging from about 140 days after
190 days those constitutes that have
cows for longer periods on pasture was
the one uh that produced Morgan house
gas emission right so base again based
on that model
um so now this study that I also did
some comparison like this look at a
graze intensity uh of farms also from
Wisconsin
and and they have different grazing
scenarios from G1 to D5 and G1 being the
ones with last grass grazing the diet
about nine percent of the total intake
and G5 be one of the highest amount of
of Grazing In the diet but overall it's
somewhat comparable you can see the
methane again it was in blue here uh
basically is that it's the the highest
source of of greenhouse gas it's not a
surprise here
um that's based on what we have been
discussing uh but what I want to
highlight here very quickly is when they
add grain in the diet there's more grain
in the diet like in the G2 scenario here
they have more grain they drop methane
the same thing here with this all the
scenarios only add more grain like G5
here uh there's more grain in the diet
so you drop that drop the whole
greenhouse gas emissions
um and then the two confinement systems
the C1 and C to those confinement system
either have an aerobic digestion or not
when they have their neurotic digester
you can see that it dropped also the
greenhouse gas emissions mostly because
you reduce manure methane right that
doesn't mean a VM menu so that's scan
that's a possibility that's a good thing
and ends in line what we have been
discussing here right so we discuss
about terminology did some comparisons
now I would like to move on and and talk
a little bit about some dietary
strategies to mitigate methane
um
so there's several ways to do that
through forage quality I think Larry
mentioned a little bit of that
um and I will be exploding a little bit
uh 40G secondary compounds uh things
like content standings glucosinolates
condensed some legumes like birds food
prefer had higher levels of content
standings
um I'll talk a little bit about
glucosinolates
um supplementation strategies like
feeding grains feeding oil oil seeds not
mentioned this today because of time
some feed additives like monensy nitrate
or nitroxy propanol 3 NOP automation a
little bit of that today and also
seaweeds
um which is another option as well so
and starting with the forage quality we
have been doing some studies with
brassicas right so brassicas is include
things like KO or Canola
um and and they are very winter hardener
hardness
um they can stand very low temperatures
but that is good because you could
potentially extend the grazing season
and they can also be used as a cover
crop there are data out there showing
that it can reduce methane emissions
that these are data that was done in
vitro in the lab
um High biomass and high nutritional
value so this is a good candidate right
that we have been looking at so we did a
study here at UNH where you have cows
who use training organic cows either the
cows were in the control diet so 10 of
them in confinement all day long and the
other group workouts half of the day in
the barn receiving
Eternal mixed ration and then they move
to graze the canola right so that's how
we set up this study and this was what
that meta knowledge that I mentioned
just to give an idea very quickly here
the diet has about six percent forage
right the control diet the canola diet
has the same level of forage but to
replace some of the daily some of the
hay with Canola in the diet
that's grazing source and and we we
allow we the calculations were those
cows would receive about 42 pounds of
dry matter from from bastards
and this is just the layout of the study
you can see the bond is here the cows
walk to the to the grazing areas and
every strip here represents uh a a strip
of forage granola daily that was offered
after the milking of the after the
afternoon milking right and you use two
fields to destroy adjacent adjacent
Fields here
um to complete uh they study again we
use the Green Feed system I mentioned
this uh to actually measure methane uh
when you look at methane production and
and and and we did the magazines on on
on week three and week five of they
study you can see the methane production
decrease by 35 when the cows are grazing
the forage canola which was
you know important reduction methane
yield uh decreased by 29 you can see
here thousand degrees in canola has
lower methane yields
um which is grams of methane per
kilogram of dry matter intake and
methane intensity decreased by 28 again
grams of methane per kilogram of NH
corrected milk so those are kind of
exciting uh uh uh data here based on
this uh forage canola
so why made that happen I said as Larry
mentioned so high quality forage and
that's happened with Canola so you can
see here the crude protein and and ndf
which basically the fiber is now crude
protein is high you know range between
20 27 percent uh and and fiber is low
right so it's highly digestible
um lots of sugars which fermentable
energy
right so that may explain why methane
was reduced
another aspects is the Roman via phase
that we have been discussing and I
mentioned earlier
so acetate right dropped on the canola
diet as you can see here
and propionate went up remember that
propionate is a hydrogen sink removes
hydrogen from the from the system and
acetate gives out hydrogens right so
less hydrogen in the system means less
uh last Med thing and another another
thing that makes going on here with
Canola and this I want to mention this
very quickly here uh this was study that
was done in in Kathy's solder lab so
they have the simulated Lumen system
meaning this is a simulated room and as
you can see here in those bottles right
and they take Lumen fluid from the
cannulated cow and then do some
inoculations with buffers and so forth
and create an environment that's similar
to the rumen and they test that in that
system and they they saw a a negative
correlation between methane emissions
and glucosinolates glucosinolates is a
compound that is hot that's relatively
high in brassicas and and there is
different types of glucosinolates as you
can see this kind of fancy names here
that I'm not trying to mention here to
pronunciate but you can see that that
there is negative correlation with with
some of them like this gluco breast
scene here uh meaning more of this
compound last methane and and they also
see you saw the one here glucoraphenine
and the total so overall there was a
negative correlation more glucosinoids
less methane so this may explain why
methane drop when we we when when my
cows here are doing a Grace canola right
still on this high quality forage aspect
this is another state it was done by in
Ireland
and what's interesting here is that so
the either cows was fed in TMR in the
confinement or they grazing perennial
high grafts so very high quality grass
so they saw a drop in methane of 27
percent
methane production methane yields
dropped 12 and and methane intensity
dropped also 12 so again why while you
know perennial High Grass rye grass is
very high quality grass and if it's on
early maturity uh like you can see in a
rotational rotational gradient system so
you can see the crude protein is high 24
and fibers is relatively low right 46
ndf 24 ADF very high digestibility
83 so when you combine this that you may
see why uh methane production will drop
when you're comparing cows grazing
perennial right grass with a TMR diet
and confinement right so there's some
options there
um and now I want to move to seaweeds
have another five minutes or so here
um and this is a couple of studies that
has been done in Penn State and another
one in in in UC Davis
um so they stated that was done in in in
Penn State with this red seaweed cause
paragraphsi tax forms and they fed
different amounts from zero to zero
point five percent in the diet not a lot
right and they saw substantial
reductions in in in in in in methane
production if you compare you know the
zero percent diet of the 0.5 diet so
methane production dropped a lot 34
methane you drop 29 and methane
intensity dropped 26 right so why that's
speculations is because of bromophore
bromoform is very high in the seaweed uh
in this red seaweed species so it may be
related to why you see uh this drop it
basically inhibits the growth of
methanogens all those microbes that
produce methane
in the rumen so in the beef Kettle also
even more pronounced so this this study
here was done in you see Dave's and they
measure this in beef cattle
well they saw with the same levels of
the seaweed and the same species they
observe as 60 reduction in methane
production a 68 reduction in methane
yield and a 73 reduction in methane
intensity in this case here is grams of
methane per kilogram of gain average
daily weight gain so
again the bromoform is likely involved
the closest thing that we have in terms
of data with this asparagobs tax forms
in terms of grazing is a study that I
collaborate with cat is sold again and
at this point we did basically in vitro
instead of using that fermenters as you
can see here that simulate the Lumen
environment and it's and we fed uh up to
1.5 percent of uh asparagapses in the
diet and this is we did this because we
did not those studies that I just
mentioned was not published yet and
we're following some uh data that was
from other in vitro studies but what
what happened and and you can see here
on the top line that's is the diet where
cows were fed uh not a house the in
vitro system was receiving a Orchard
Grass diet right so that a pasture diet
and then and we supplement that the
pasture diet with the seaweed there is
no grain in this diet and and basically
uh simulating a grass-fed system or what
happened is methane dropped almost to
zero
in three hours after we start the
inoculation process after we add the
seaweed to the system and then as you
can see it remains at zero uh uh uh you
know for long periods of time of the day
right so it's really effective in drop
methane again bromophore may be involved
we don't necessarily want to obliterate
methane like you've seen this study and
for sure we've had too much you may not
need 1.5 in the diet uh but you can see
that basically uh uh uh move methane
down very very quickly
right so and again these were simulating
a a fashion diet right another one
another mitigation strategy that's out
there is the
this study was done at Penn State and
three NOP again three initroxypropanol
is is a product that's not yet available
in us not being approved by FDA however
in other countries like I know like in
Brazil is approved and I think in Chile
it's been has been approved
um and also seems very promising you can
see here in this study that was done
over 12 weeks which it's kind of good
because it's relatively long the control
diet here is in the top in the cows were
supplemented with different levels of
NLP and low in median and high dose uh
the those are in the bottom here you can
see so you can see that drop methane
production in approximately 30 percent
right when you look at methane intensity
grams of methane per kilogram of NH
correct with milk kind of the same Trend
uh about 20 reduction between 20 and 30
percent reduction in methane intensity
so again it's promising
um but it's not yet approved in the U.S
and then to to kind of finalize here
um
uh Larry mentioned those comparisons
between 1940 cow and a 2007 cow and then
a 2007 cow with a 2017 cow one thing
that we know the U.S dairy industry it
has made
uh impressive change right if you see
this data here from USDA Nas you know
from 1970 to 2018 you can even you know
EAS easily find the the data up to now
actually up to this year but so you can
see here in the orange line that's the
milk production and in the blue line
that's the number of cows so the number
of cows drop almost front from 1970 you
have about 12 billion cows right now you
have around 9 million cows right so
about 3 million last cows and milk
production increased uh almost double in
the same time frame right from 120 uh
billion pounds of milk producing a year
here to about 220 so this basically
shows the improvements in genetics
Animal Health
um Technologies on those dairies and and
and nutrition as well right so
um
to summarize the meta Knights that we
did uh show that cows that are grazing
they they eat less and they produce less
milk and milk components however but
they have similar estimated methane you
then methane intensity and also similar
milk nitrogen efficiency uh however I
want to mention here that this data
should be interpreted cautiously because
we have a low number of treatment mean
comparisons only 14 right
there's some promising here with Forest
canola the the seaweed asparagobs tax
form is for sure rats you eat and also
the three NOP right this this they show
substantial reductions in methane
production yield and intensity
um so those are promising uh feeding
strategies in the future I mean it's
ongoing but but in terms of future
research I think uh we need a long-term
feeding trials
um specifically with this red seaweed
those those studies that I show I mean
the study that I showed with the dairy
was a short-term uh Latin Square design
type of study we need continuous type of
design uh with with feeding seaweeds uh
with the rats you eating in Grazing In
not only in confinement but also in
grazing cows right uh there are limited
information regarding the use of
seaweeds and three NOP on grazing there
I heard I think that is as far as I know
there's no studies with the NLP and
raising herds I may be wrong but I think
that's that's the case
um so we need more data on this for sure
um also scores information on how
seaweeds and three NOP can impact Animal
Health and also consumers acceptance
um and I also I think that further
research is needed to either to optimize
current or approach or identify new
approach that you can see simultaneously
decrease both methane production and
intensity in a cost effectively manner
to produce that's that's a key here as
well so if that electric knowledge some
of the funding source of some of the
studies that I showed here also Jennifer
for the invitation
um to participate and now we can open up
some questions
thank you Andre that was fantastic I
gave a resounding Applause to both you
and Larry
um thank you so much for sharing your
work today
um if uh we're going to post a poll
um
for everybody to just respond if you
could do that that would be great
um
and I will start with the questions the
first question is from uh Brad Ted zoy
is the red seaweed the same as the
ground kelp supplements readily
available as a livestock supplement if
not do you know if it if kelp has a
similar benefit
no it's not the same so the kelp that is
available
um
basically a lot of competent cell kelp
they call kelp meal is found another
seaweeds actually is a brown seaweed
called escoffillen a dozen
I we have done studies here at two and
eight uh with uh with kelp and data are
not promising in one grazing trial that
we did it only reduced methane uh in we
measured throughout the grading season
and and only change methane early in the
season uh and the reduction was quite
low about 10 percent
um we follow up with another study that
was done during the winter the cows were
in confinement and we fed
quite a lot of that kelp meal and did
not change methane emissions at all
um what I can share in terms of the
seaweed with testing another seaweeds
called chondros Crispus which is
available locally here in the Gulf of
Maine
um and that one seems a little bit more
promising uh is also red seaweed and
drop methane up to 15
so but we need more studies on that one
okay thank you so Dickens Crane or dick
and crane asks does the carbon emissions
from grass-fed cows account for the
emissions produced by the grain
production compared with the grazing our
other offsets like Transportation
emissions accounted for
well I I would think that is accounted
for uh on on on those scenarios because
all those scenarios that I show uh thus
do have grain uh grain being fed to
those cows so as far as I know with the
uh the ifsm model the integrated Farm
systems model does account for grain
production yes in transportation as well
I mean
Transportation not sure it accounts for
the farm equipment and and farm uh
tractors and and equipment I know that
account
I will just say on on sort of the
national and state inventories those are
accounted but they're accounted in
different areas depending on on how the
inventory
accounting scheme is organized
um
uh so
the next question is from Kristen uh
Kirsten Workman with three NLP be
allowable under Organic certification
programs
I don't think so and and I mean because
they say
synthetic product I think it's it's it's
basically
so as I know uh
the fact that the way that inhibit
methane it's the competitive inhibition
because it it it's like a enzyme right
it inhibits the last step of
methanogenesis uh it seems is a
synthetic product and as a synthetic
product is not allowing organic system
which is
well it's I guess in one way
unfortunately but the fact because
by definition Organic Farms nature
grades right but to be certified and the
cows must consume at least 30 percent of
the intake coming from pasture so I
think overall grazing has fuel fuel
options than than confinement and but
there's I'll say not not only in the U.S
but but maybe worthwhile you know
there's way more grazing cows than than
confinement if you really think about it
uh fienna Fiona has asked how easily
will it be to convince Dairy Farmers to
produce or to purchase and adopt novel
feed supplements do you foresee
voluntary carbon markets helping with
production
oh I would think you know what I can say
some of this this product
that are promising like that the rats
you eat and the tree on op uh would add
costs right right now this this the
dreads you eat it seems well one thing
it's Wild Harvest it's really expensive
it's producing in in Australia or in
Portugal I know there is some groups in
in Hawaii that some companies that are
trying to grow that you know aquaculture
system there is issues in terms of
biomass it's highly invasive uh there's
a lot of a lot of things going on there
on on the the asparagapsis end of things
um and and it's expensive the trionopia
I don't know how much cost is but I
think the bottom line is if the farmers
if there is any incentive like you just
said carbon credits and things like that
I see
they they adopting but at the moment
where they basically you know their
farmers are struggling just to
specifically median and small size to
just to keep keep alive in the you know
keep producing milk
I I I I think it's more difficult if
there is no some sort of incentives like
carbon credit or something along those
lines to to subsidize some of this
okay it is 11 o'clock
um I have earning I have one burning
question myself for you
um but we have officially ended this
meeting
um thank you all for joining us you will
see that the recordings will be posted
seven uh days uh from today on our
website and the link is in the chat box
and we have more webinars coming up
February 8th Monroe management and
greenhouse gases March 8th field
nitrogen and greenhouse gases April 12th
to be determined and made times food
waste and greenhouse gases and you can
register for those in that link to the
side
um
uh thank you Larry and Andre for joining
us and if I could just ask my one
burning question Andre before you go
um so the archaea are only one percent
of the the the rumen in terms of the
population their methanogens and they're
the ones who are making the methane
um and but they're providing a service
to the god of the rumen which is they're
a sink for the hydrogen that is produced
from all of these other processes and so
um
that is presumably keeping the rumen
from becoming extremely acidic correct
so we can't knock out those archaea
because they're providing a really
important service to the health of the
gut
and
and Larry made a point in the beginning
that was really great about how um you
know
if you have methane you're not properly
using up all of your foodstuffs right so
I'm just curious
is it
what are some of the things that we
should be thinking about when we are
considering adding feed amendments to
the diet
um to think about both the well-being of
the cow as well as what ends up in the
manure which then ends up on the field
like how should we as a society be
thinking critically about how those food
amendments are affecting the ecology in
the room and in order to reduce that
methane so that we aren't
um
being foolish and also understanding
that bacteria you know they double every
20 minutes or every two days depending
on the species and they're highly
evolving creatures right so how can can
you share with us your thoughts on how
we can be sensitive since Optical
yeah I mean well there are a couple of
things here well one thing as I said
um we cannot eliminate methane just
because it's well it's a natural product
and and just by Evolution right millions
of millions of years that were there
uh feeding that ecological niche there
for the cows basically disposal of
hydrogen so the fermentation can keep
going
um so
that I feel that
uh uh uh I guess the the point here is
not
uh completely eliminate methane uh it it
decreases methane two levels uh
that we can let's say 30 to 35 percent
if you achieve that on a cow
30 to 35 reduction in methane
consistently means even though some of
the studies that we show here that
measure to 12 weeks uh that's not the
full lactation cycle because doing full
lactation cycle studies is very
expensive but that may be some of the
needs out there
um so to really pass this in the full
lactation cycle
um so one thing is persistency right uh
it's very important that consistent keep
things dull because microbes make
basically as you mentioned evolve and
then at the same time they may not be
more sensitive to some of those uh or
bromoform or glucosinolates or 3no B so
we don't know that so we need to do more
long-term studies so the other aspect is
the cost effective and Effectiveness and
application of those so those needs to
be considered in any way shape or form
that they want to to design strategies
to mitigate methane
um
uh
you know I guess I guess that just to
summarize I think we should look for
reduction mitigation that are consistent
and important like levels of 30 to 40
percent if that's you know and
consistently and cost effective you know
it's it's
I'll feel these are are important
targets
I know they're difficult to reach but
um should be considered in in and also
doing some of these long-term studies
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu